[Music]
trust me i've called a few people a
donut in my time but if you're looking
to turn up the heat on a delicious donut
recipe in 10 minutes then you better
watch closely because i'm about to show
you how to make the most extraordinary
donuts with the beautiful fragrant chili
dipping sauce right oscar pandama man
ricotta so it's a recipe with no yeast
super fast delicious
plain flour eggs vanilla extract sugar
and then for the sauce we've got this
amazing beautiful dark chocolate
beautiful
smoked chipotle paste and that gives it
that little bit of sort of
intriguingness across the doughnut
smoked mold and salt and fish a little
bit of honey zest of orange over the
donuts right let's have 10 minutes on
the clock first up get you all on
okay
now i'm using a peanut oil okay and just
bring it up to temperature don't go too
crazy and literally two inches on the
bottom not half full not two thirds full
and then on standby i've always got some
cold oil because if it is getting too
hot move it off carefully and just add a
touch of cold oil and that'll bring the
temperature down immediately never start
off with the gas at full nice and low
bring that up to temp and take your time
with that okay
now for the mixture
the ricotta in this is an exciting
recipe because there's no yeast and it's
almost like a sort of
spicy delicious rich chocolate donut
mix in that ricotta okay lightly beat it
okay
from there get your eggs always crack
them on a flat surface that way you get
no shell in there whatsoever and we're
gonna lightly whisk that okay i'm gonna
put that
in the bowl
whisk
with a fork
now
first off because the cotton is wet and
the eggs are wet don't add them together
okay
flour in first
okay that will turn the ricotta really
nice and dry
now mix that up okay
lightly bring it together bicarb soda in
that bicarb gives it the sort of
aeration okay and then a nice pinch of
cinnamon okay
i quite like the flavor cinnamon in
there sugar
goes in
sprinkle that in there
and then
your vanilla extract you can use
a vanilla bean but just literally one
little cup in there
now
mix that in
create a little well in the middle and
then start adding your egg don't throw
all your egg in two thirds in and fold
that in and you'll see this coming
together almost like a really nice dough
okay
and now if we over mix it it makes the
dough too tight okay so
you can see i'm not going crazy whisking
just nice and gently
lift that in oil's getting nice and warm
i'm going to slide that to the side
and then look
i'm just going to mix that up
and then from there
because this is a quick recipe
okay you don't need to leave this to
rest
now bring this together nice and
carefully don't over mix it okay it sort
of should almost look like a a nice
pliable dough almost like you're making
beautiful bread now just let it sit
there okay
for two minutes
get your pan for the dipping sauce gas
on
very low okay
start off with
get your cream in
and this is a really nice delicious
sauce because it's a really nice way of
either coating or glazing
your donuts nice tablespoon of honey in
okay
and then this magic here let's say
chipotle
smoked paste a teaspoon of that in only
okay
a little touch
of salt
mix that in don't bring it to the boil
but just mix it in a way that it
actually just comes
together and melts that's all
okay
once it starts to melt
get your chocolate
okay and just break that up
now the secret here is not to boil it
okay if you boil it you're gonna turn
the sauce into sort of a granular mess
let it melt
and just sort of come on and off the
heat
once the cream starts to
melt it helps melt the chocolate
but
don't bring the temperature up too much
okay otherwise they'll absolutely
destroy that chocolate
that smokiness is in there and it's so
beautiful
and look
it's just starting to melt come down
please oscar it's a bit of heat in the
pan and you see that chocolate melting
and don't boil it
and look you've got this beautiful nice
smooth
rich
incredible
dipping sauce so beautiful and that
smokiness adds that nice little bit of
excitement to those donuts
right donuts
take a little spoon
and just
we sort of we say cornell but just drop
that in
okay put the oil up to temp
and literally into the fryer
the nice thing about these donuts they
do not need to be perfectly shaped i
like
literally heating my spoon in the oil
and that way you get to sort of cut into
the shape of that donut
gas up now because the temperature's
coming down
heat the spoon again in
and look you just come up the side of
the bowl and you sort of almost
twirl your spoon get that nice spoonful
in
in again
and it comes off the spoon
almost like
the old-fashioned cornell hot spoon in
and turned
now you can make this dough up the day
before and it relaxes beautifully
they'll puff up a little bit
in
and back off
be careful it's hot oil so just be very
very careful
often the spoon
in
and there you go you can see these
things puffing up now i've got room for
one more don't overfill that
in
and look
the dough comes off that beautiful hot
spoon
now we're rocking time please
four minutes amazing who would have
thought we could make a donut literally
in 10 minutes now gently roll that
around and all we're doing now is
coating those beautiful donuts they take
about
two
two and a half minutes as they start to
rise whenever you're frying anything the
minute it starts to rise
it's cooked but
i want to get it nice and sort of light
okay
they come out onto a paper
and we're going to literally just turn
those over
look
i want the color on there
really important i've got enough heat in
the oil now so i'm going to turn that
gas off there's enough residual heat in
there from the keep frying but look at
them
so beautiful
and it's such a good pick-me-up
especially for a sort of you know party
kids party or even a little treat for a
dessert
after a wonderful dinner
beautiful time please
back on to give that last sort of 60
seconds blast i'm using the spoon and
i'm turning these over
you can just see
a beautiful color on there
that dipping sauce smells incredible
now
very carefully
take them out
and look that's beautiful
just check that's lovely
nicely cooked it is
out
once they're hot okay
you need to sprinkle the sugar on them
quickly
that way they'll absolutely
stick
so
sugar on
around
and then with your orange zest
literally
on top
and then just let that sit there
but that is a beautiful
delicious
fresh
ricotta
donut that
is done
with ease and more importantly finesse
now
finish that finally with some orange
zest
and look
you did not think this was possible but
there we have the most amazing
ricotta donuts
with an amazing deliciously spicy
chipotle chocolate dipping sauce your
donut excellent
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsay intend if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsey
intent cookbook inspired by this series
and trust me you're going to come out a
much better chef and if you like this
video don't forget to subscribe to my
amazing youtube channel for more good
luck